speaking of terrible people
elizabeth warren who is a crazy
socialist from uh massachusetts she went
on the
the view i have to do we have the we
have there we go content advisory
warning what you're about to see is pure
[ __ ] elizabeth warren went on the
view and we showed you this video
yesterday uh of lindsey granger she is a
guest host so i guess she's testing out
to see if she can be the conservative on
the view because obviously you have to
have four liberals and one conservative
because that's a fair makeup of america
and lindsey granger who's spectacular
and i want to get her on the show she
just wrecked sonny hostin yesterday when
sonny hostin basically said you know you
can't have black republicans like it's
just it's just so awful and racist by
sunny hostin and joy and the rest of the
clowns but anyway elizabeth warren was
on yesterday and talking about student
loan debt and lindsey granger made a
great point hey what about all the
people that have worked and busted their
butts to pay off their student loans
i mean you've been fiercely advocating
for the president to cancel student loan
debts but really only 13
of americans even have federal student
loan debt so is this really the best way
to reach most voters and also what do
you say to someone like me who worked
two jobs for a decade to pay off all
their student loans just finished where
do i sign up for reimbursement so let's
start out
with
who has student loans today
about 40 percent of the folks with
student loans don't have a college
diploma
they're folks who tried yeah they're
folks who tried and life happened
pregnancies uh they were already working
two jobs and lost one of them
mom got sick family had to move
somewhere else and now they earn what a
high school grad earns and they're
trying to pay off
college-level debt and it is crushing
their bones
okay first off could someone possibly
come off as more inauthentic right like
so in other folks the folks the folks
she didn't answer the question at all
the question was hey what about someone
like me who busted my butt who worked
two jobs to pay off my debt you're gonna
take care of me you're gonna you're
gonna pay me back for all that and then
what what elizabeth warren does there is
standard leftist 101 she makes up sort
of an imaginary situation about these
people and and she she's playing to your
emotion now we might be able to figure
out some ways to help some of those
people i'm actually not completely
against some of that but i would also
say that maybe not everyone has to go to
four-year universities maybe you should
go to trade school maybe you should
learn things outside of the university
system and give a little power back to
yourself and not go a hundred thousand
dollars into debt to have a four-year
degree in lesbian archery to then not
have any skills and also been taught
that america's evil the entire time and
everything else uh so elizabeth warren
has no answers for anything other than
we the government want more of your
money to pay off other people's problems
and it's just [ __ ] and nobody nobody
buys it anymore and that's why she comes
off as so what does elizabeth warren
always she always comes off as the sort
of librarian who is holier than thou and
she really cares about everybody more
than you by the way her kids even though
she's a big proponent of public schools
her kids went to private school she also
pretended to be a native american to get
a job i mean these are horrible people
but what do they have they have they're
holier holier-than-thou attitude and
these folks and i really care about
these folks or they have their crazy
outrage which remember we had the video
the other day she's very angry about
abortion she wants as many dead babies
as possible i i've never seen you so
angry you seem to be this is what
the republicans have been working toward
this day angling more
for decades now and we are gonna fight
the they've become the party of tyrants
and big government losers so the rest of
us have to be the party and i don't mean
political party we should be an actual
party with music and drinking and fun
and happiness and smiles of free people
that agree that humanity is a little bit
messy or all we're going to do is create
the conditions
so that you might have a chance to live
the life that you want to live